j'ouvre la bouche j'ouvre la bouche de
mes victimes je regarde ok je vais
coller mon oreille collée majou
rapprochés et je vais regarder son
ventre pour voir s'il respire gestes qui
sauvent sensibilisation avec les forces
de l'ordre quiz sur les institutions ou
encore circuit sécurité routière autant
d'ateliers auxquels ont participé près
de 180 élèves de maurepas vendredi 13
avril des classes de cm1 cm2 et 6e
toutes venues à cette journée préparée
par leurs enseignants afin de mieux
appréhender un thème cher qui figurent
au programme scolaire la citoyenneté
les élèves sont capables de comprendre
très jeune les notions de citoyenneté et
son
ils peuvent les transmettre dans leur
famille les retransmettre à l'école et
ils sont tout à fait capables de
comprendre ces notions la dette plus
jeune âge au cours de la journée les
enfants réunis en petits groupes ont pu
suivre un parcours à travers une dizaine
de stands
rencontre avec des pompiers policiers et
bénévoles j'utilise un côté genou pour
tirer ma victime et regardez c'est
magique c'est un levier ça parce que la
victime faire le plein de connaissances
civiques y adopter certains bons
réflexes notamment pour les premiers
secours
tu mets ton bras comme ça et ensuite on
fera cuire comme celui ci ni respire on
a appris à savoir comment utiliser
internet
comment
sauver des vies avec les pompiers moi je
peux supporter lt ainsi je retrouve
quelqu'un par terre et aussi j'apprends
comment ne pas être renversé par une
voiture propre quand ils traversent une
journée qui a séduit la municipalité et
l'inspection académique le rendez vous
devrait être élargie dans les prochaines
années aux autres écoles de maurepas